one of my favorite movies and this is
not a joke this is for Real as a kid and
obviously it was way before our time too
but it was always on was Willy Wonka
right Willy Wonka was [__] amazing
yeah
um
you know he's he's a [__] a force in
films well so then they make another
they made another one and it was of
course
um such an [__] it was it was the
Johnny Depp one or whatever but you know
what we needed because and I blame
Marvel for this Disney for this do you
know what we needed Marsh
An Origin film for Willy Wonka because
you know when I was watching Willy
Wonka's a kid I was wondering I wonder
how he owned this chocolate fact yeah
question sure you know what I do know I
read the [__] book you don't need a
go ahead okay book aside yeah most of us
didn't read the book all right
um
at least from the film viewing uh
perspective wasn't part of the whole
Wonka like Mystique the part of it like
wasn't it just that he was mysterious
yeah weird and like you know couldn't
really tell if he was Supernatural where
he came from where he came from doesn't
affect us he makes the character worse
yep thank you thank you it's the same
way like you I don't need to know where
the Wizard of Oz came from I also don't
need to know how the Joker was actually
made like I it's it's it's more like wow
this is a [__] up dude and not knowing
you know or in this case an eccentric
dude and not doing knowing was part of
the story well too [__] bad I don't
need an hour of exposition explaining to
me that Captain ahab's dad had a
drinking problem and was mean at home
yeah
you guys never wanted a thought bubble
over Leatherface's head
yeah okay
oh my God that's true
sounds
[Laughter]
holy [__]
I've spent the past seven years
traveling the world perfecting my craft
you see I'm something of a magician
inventor and chocolate maker so quiet up
and listen down nope scratch that
reverse
oh my God this
okay go
let's just go
Johnny did the line from the movie The
Johnny Depp version already sucked right
oh my God it was so but go back and
watch the original right
there's such a like they're they're just
trying to cash in on a [__] IP and I
get that right they're like we own the
IP might as well make some money off the
[__] thing but like you're never
gonna recreate the Eerie because I'm not
a big like Willy Wonka and the Chocolate
Factory on every level is a genre of
movie I shouldn't like I shouldn't enjoy
that movie I don't like movies like it
but for some reason that movie is
magical it's creepy and weird and Gene
Wilder's amazing the direction the
cinema talk the whole thing is a [__]
goddamn drug-induced fever dream you
know and that's why I can watch it and
go man this movie's still just
fascinates me but what do you do and
you're just gonna get some wacky young
guy is that Tom Holland by the way
no it's uh it's not Tom Holland it's um
Minecraft the other kid from stranger
things the other kids yeah I mean that's
the only way to describe it with the
other kid from stranger things that
sounds like a honest kid from that
sounds like an honest movie trailer
featuring the other kid from stranger
things it's actually it's actually the
also the kid that was in Dune movie
and June something inventor and
chocolate maker so quiet up and listen
down nope scratch that reverse it
Mr Wonka I can say you're a man a great
Ingenuity so something else can I can I
put something else out here wait
they're also making it seem like he
always dressed in the same outfit like
[__] Peter in Family Guy yeah like so
he had a top hat even as a kid like it's
kind of getting it later okay so one
clock and say you're a man a great
engineering what are you doing meme
Comics you want to know how I got these
scars I mean Gobstoppers
I'm making chocolate of course how do
you like it dark white nutty absolutely
insane
absolutely insane many people have come
here to sell chocolate they've all been
fresh but like he wasn't they're trying
to Harry Potter they're trying to Harry
Potter up Willy wonk that's they're
trying to Harry Potter up everything
yeah but you were correct in that yeah
even in it like that's go watch they're
doing that with everything everything's
Whimsical and Harry and yes and when oh
ye Olde English music and flipping
around on the uh on the old style uh
street lights and it's those books
shouldn't be stacked that way
he's gonna run into a younger version of
the grandpa too as a little callback
that's gonna happen what happened let's
yes but I do like the um also the like
absolutely insane like he wasn't the Mad
Hatter they understand that's because
they have the Hat do you understand
Willy Wonka thought Willy Wonka was
perfectly fine Willy Wonka thought hey
I'm perfectly normal you normies are
[__] weird like he didn't go around
going
I am so crazy he thought he was normal
oh someone's got a good point and we
gotta do it and we gotta do it hold on
the Harry Potter the Harry Potter
trailer
oh no oh no oh no it's coming
Harry Potter thing and then [__]
before you do that down to 75 and we've
got a Harry Potter I'm gonna predict
something when we finish watching the
actual trailer there's gonna be a point
where it's gonna go like blah blah blah
and then you're gonna go come with me
can I try it can I can I try can I try
trailer core version of it okay let's do
it
[Music]
hahaha
bro bring us to Hollywood this is easy
this is an easy job it's perfect
perfect it lines at us
[__] man in a world void of hope I hate
the world we live in now it's everything
just cut and paste
all they needed
was an imagination Ted Kaczynski was
right
no seriously laptops final let it pro
ruins the whole world right
um go live there's a cabin in a dream go
live buttons ruined everything
yeah you know when movies were good when
when [__] Martin Scorsese was up late
night snipping pieces of film himself
and splicing it also I wasn't aware in
the original he could defy gravity
they've all been crushed by the
chocolate cocktail chocolate cartel what
can't get a shock without selling
chocolate
so then he goes and starts working for
the cartel and he makes really good
chocolate for them but then like Gus
friend gets mad is that the that would
have been yeah that'd be [__] amazing
that actually would have been see now if
I if we just wrote like a parody Willy
Wonka movie and that was the origin
story and and like it ends with like him
living unlike Walter White and he goes
on to be uh chocolate yeah you know what
this is Jesse this is an everlubbing
gobstop
he's yelling at the guy you've been
aping my product every chance you get
you're even dyeing it with food coloring
say my name
that's your goddamn right oh [__] uh so
I'm the guy who killed David chocolate
steam or whatever
chili recipe so answer me this Charlie
is a movie okay come on
and you can't sell chocolate without a
shop
well you can do it online probably do
like a
what what what what uh Chuck Norris Gun
Club don't sell in my territory so we
had black constables back in Ye Olde and
Willy Wonka days no daydreaming penalty
Three Dog what is this movie uh on the
job so we want to be we want to be Harry
Potter yes uh we want to be uh uh uh we
want to be uh Pleasantville
Wes Anderson the Wes Anderson stuff
going on here too I hate all of this uh
on the John this is not uh what I wanted
for my birthday be right back I'm ending
it that's your 30.
huh
a double hop to the pencil and paper
uh-huh I got an idea you want me to go
deal with this do you need to go out too
because she was moving around she's all
right all right we're almost done things
haven't been easy for you they're gonna
get better you promise
of course
there it is a pinky promise that's the
most solid man they really just wanna
they really just wanna keep the money
printing from the Harry Potter World
they just really don't want to give JK
Rowling anything that's exactly what
this is we start
good chocolate said Mr Bean
was that Mr B yeah yeah oh I don't know
if he's playing he's always that would
be weird
[Music]
what's happening oh that's a chocolate
that makes you fly let's find out shall
we ask from a callback dude ever again
can't you call a callback but the way
people are talking it's so like you said
it's just Harry Potter who's forever
science [__] Chuck Norris Gun Club
says apathetic Crow I hate movies yep
it's a call back it was a drink it was a
[__] drink hold on damn it I gotta I
we uh uh
here you go
let's get to the best part here
the world's ever seen
there you go
funny little man who's been following me
I will have you know yes that's Hugh
Grant is an Oompa Loompa so can I ask
something is that a nightmare yeah so
this is the origin story about how he
was making magic chocolate and then the
Oompa Loompas came and then he enslaves
them he enslaves them yeah because
that's what they were and they were
slaves they were slaves chocolate
when you trade someone's chocolate for
the labor and they have to live in with
you on your property you feed them so
we're doing the Peter we're also doing
the Peter Dinklage thing and we're not
giving swaggle any jobs we're not giving
jobs to any actual miniature people now
because we don't want to make jokes
about
like that
so you just [__] yourself out of jobs
Mercy you don't understand this Titan of
Industry went to the Oompa Loompas home
planet and he said hey come with me I
got I have jobs for you
and he took them back here and he gave
them jobs that's not slave wait Percy I
will kill you Royce and myself
that's fine okay yeah
yeah that's exactly that's your
punishment your punishment
I know what I'm doing I'm sick I'm a
sick [__] yeah you're [__]
we'll throw the throw the gun at you
like [__] like in Breaking Bad the
world do it do it yourself
say you want this yeah
too late I started dancing now
holy [__] why is this a movie
foreign
ER absolutely looked [__] better than
that because it was made by the people
made Zombieland and that at least is not
taking itself [__] seriously that's
why can I can I try to get a silver
lining out of this Cloud Sure
Hollywood people have to all be like
suffering a massive morale problem right
now oh yeah like they're all miserable
they're all unhappy the top movie in a
month is going to be Barbie there's a
writer strike like take comfort in uh
Ron Perlman cried and said he's running
over the threads yesterday these people
are broken and sad and miserable and
it's hilarious take some take some joy
in that they're Hollywood people that
have been in the business for 20 30
years are also seeing this [__] get
cranked out Hugh Grant Hugh Grant's only
job this year was an Oompa Loompa he got
caught with a hooker at a time when you
get involved with a hooker was the end
of the world and he was a bigger star he
was the biggest star in the world the
next year
yeah and now he's doing Oompa Loompa
dance